hello after the european summit of
heads of state and government in
brussels the spotlight will turn
to strasbourg the euro deputies will meet there on
Monday for a final
plenary session before the summer break
a very special session which
coincides with the arrival of the  croatia
joined the union on 1 July with
the entry of 12 croatian deputies the
parliament will have 766 meps
until the next
european elections in may 2014
bye bye island and the kid
said hello in lithuanian this will be the other
highlight of  the plenary lithuania
will take over the reins of power within
the union for six months,
succeeding ireland on tuesday dublin will therefore present
its results to the euro deputies and on wednesday
villemus will unveil its priorities for the
coming semester which revolves
around three  words a growing credible europe
is open another face
unveiled on Wednesday that of the new
European mediator who will be elected by
MEPs ago  a chance in two
that the future mediator will be an
MEP in place today is a
chance in two that it will be a woman he
or she will occupy this position until the
next European elections
finally the MEPs should vote
on a few important files he or she
should in particular vote the introduction
of a tax on financial transactions
introduced in eleven European states
objective to ensure a fairer distribution
of the costs incurred by the
financial crisis good week and see you
soon on euros by tv